layout dependent on the size of my
browser right what happens if I rotate
my phone if the dimensions of the layout
viewport change the browser has to rerun
the layout step that's what happens
every time you rotate your phone or for
that matter resize your browser hmm I
see
so our examples are pretty simple but
could this possibly be a performance
bottleneck yep let's take a look at dev
tools I've captured a trace of Gizmodo
dot-com which is a popular new site if
you're curious you can grab this trace
from the instructor notes and follow
along let's take a look first of all
there's a ton of events here since we're
only interested in layout let's filter
out the loading scripting and painting
events okay here's the first layout
event check it out it took 145
milliseconds Wow what's a long time yeah
as you can see there are over 1,400
nodes in the tree huh but there are
other layout events in here what's going
on that's a great question
recall that any time we update the
render tree either by modifying styles
or the content there's a good chance we
have to rerun layout and in this case it
looks like that's exactly what's
happening the page is adding new content
and modifying styles and hence we need
to run layout a few more times
I see so how do you go about optimizing
for that it really depends on the site
but a good rule of thumb is to batch
updates to avoid having multiple layout
events